i know some 60 year old greek ladies
that'll just knock your socks off with
the [ __ ] with the nice galacto
greek women are sexy man i'm trying to i
would fat asses on greek words
the older i get i've actually never
i don't think i've even had sex with a
greek girl i've never i've never dated
one
um and the older i get the more i'm like
do i just want to go to a village and
just find a wife that doesn't speak
english or just tear through the village
yeah yeah
everyone just yeah come back 20 years
later there's a bunch of little fat kids
running around
i would come very skies yeah yeah yeah
yeah
have you been to greece oh yeah all the
time i love it mykonos there's a story
going a big story out of mykonos uh
there's a place called dk oysters i
think interesting and there's this huge
like scam where they're like or the
people are saying they're scanning where
they're charging like
600 bucks to have like uh two crab legs
and two drinks like and they kind of
muscle you they're all weird
they're saying that the guys surround
the table until you pay the bill
yeah yeah yeah it's all over the daily
mail it's this place hysterical yeah
they're saying it's a real [ __ ] shady
deal are they getting locals with it or
tourists tourists tourists for sure yeah
because that's the i mean i don't even
go to mykono like it's like the kind of
place where you're like yeah that's it
used to be like i mean it is beautiful
beaches and that used to for
for years when i was a little kid greek
people were like oh that's where gay
guys go right that was like the the
rehoboth beach of the greek isles you
know and then it became like this
celebrities would start go there and
then it became like rich people like
when it when like the you know the
sheik's third son or whatever wants to
go vacation then that's why they can get
away with that [ __ ] because it's
like you do have in the height of it
like just rich people go there and then
if some dumb [ __ ] you know some guy
from nebraska's like i want to go to
greece it's like yeah then he's getting
shaken down for 600 crab legs because
you know
whoever you know some saudi has no
problem paying that you know right yeah
like that's they [ __ ] the money up for
everybody go to different islands if
you're broke i'll tell you that much
don't go to santorini don't go to mikko
no yeah they asked everything they said
that what they do is they get you on the
beach and they'll like offer you like a
free lounge chair or something if you
come in and the waiter will hold the
menu and not give it to you
and they charge by the gram like
everything is
per 100 grams and everything is like 300
grams but the pricing is per hundred
grams so you have no idea you're just
getting tripled on automatically it's
true yeah they're selling seafood like
it's cocaine yeah
[ __ ] gram that's hysterical well can
i just get one gram no we only sell four
grams can i get a dime bag of crab legs
[Laughter]
yes sixteen hundred and forty dollars
for two dishes salad and bread jesus
is probably dog [ __ ] too but that's like
to the point that like that's absurdity
yeah like it's one thing to like
you know get it up to like 300 bucks or
something where it's like all right we
got we got him we got him but like
that's a crime now it's sixteen hundred
dollars that's like yeah because you've
violated somebody the owner doesn't look
like the type of guy who would do this
either he looks like a very upstanding
guy
[Laughter]
yeah i wouldn't trust a greek business
owner at all you would not no no
certainly not here's here's the i mean
that looks like it does take pretty good
it looks good it doesn't look a
used toyota corolla good you know what i
mean like it doesn't look [ __ ]
i i could buy a hyundai elantra for my
little cousin with that with what they
paid for that meal but let me tell you
something you know who would be [ __ ]
going to this restaurant who's the
situation
god damn i can't do that i can't do it
babe i'm broke he just calls his wife
she's like i can't i can't fly home i
can't
i can't i have to pawn off the plane
ticket i bought i ate all this calamari
yeah people are trying to get them shut
down and i guess it ain't happening they
might be connected it ain't happening
you think so no you know what they'll do
is the daily mail will send in a
reporter to record it and they'll order
some stuff i didn't know about like
they'll they'll get them but you read
the reviews are really funny avoid
i would have posted this earlier but i
can't afford internet that is honestly
they got the full greek experience
because they you go to greece you see
the beautiful beaches and some [ __ ]
guy in a wife beater and too much gold
jewelry shakes shakes you down for a
thousand dollars that's that's full
that's that's what being greek is like
what do you do go see the ruins and
stuff when you're there yeah i mean
honestly that if you've never been to
athens it's [ __ ] wild it's like
the the museum the parthenon museum is
unbelievable and they they remade it so
it's like exactly they've done like a
reconstruction of what it looked like at
the time so it's like this insane thing
and then you walk in that neighborhood
and that neighborhood has been a
functioning marketplace since
like then so you these [ __ ] you walk
through these stones and you're like
some [ __ ] like four foot semi
prehistoric man wrapped in a tunic was
over here like buying little beads to
get [ __ ] three four thousand years ago
he was trying to figure out like that's
what's so crazy i feel like americans
don't have a concept of history because
like for us
anything more than 250 years ago is a
fairy tale like yeah this is nonsense
this is something that people just made
up in a book right whereas like oh
greece it's like continuously that land
and like you know the same thing has
been here but no one wants to mention
native americans you know what i mean
we're like wow we found this place 250
years ago it's like they had [ __ ] like
that but we [ __ ] bulldozed it to put
up you know big lots you know what i
mean like but
we did make better use of the land
in fairness
so you're saying there was
thousand-year-old culture here yeah we
destroyed it yeah yeah i mean look
manhattan has been it would not be that
yeah it's gorgeous
i'll give us manhattan yeah we get that
one but i'm sure there's some [ __ ]
strip malls in florida we could have
done without probably but i mean sandals
in bahamas used to be really something
yeah yeah 100 100 how old is that uh the
parthenon uh what is it six thousand
years something like that is that old
jesus
or something like that
so it's a lot older than rome even uh
look i'm i'm gonna i could be fully
wrong but that's my guess yeah yeah yeah
i'm gonna say yeah i'm gonna say 2000 bc
something like that oh my god let's see
let's see how [ __ ]
okay 447 all right well you know i was
off by 1500. wait a minute 422 bc
yeah 432 bc i'm sorry 432. okay so it's
about uh 2500 yeah yeah we're still
pretty [ __ ] 2000 years yeah i mean
once you get past like 1500 years yeah
you know your your
point of view and i believe like that
still that neighborhood the parthenon
it's like before that it was still a
marketplace so it's like this that
neighborhood exists prior to that
it's just [ __ ] insane to think about
it
that's people were just here thousands
of years ago just going about doing
essentially the same [ __ ] buying [ __ ]
selling [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah
um in 10 bc there was some guy walking
through because there was a girl selling
fruit that he wanted to [ __ ]
absolutely some guy wasted all his
[ __ ] uh all his like um philosophy
money on figs to get [ __ ]
christ was four days old and i was
getting blown
all my [ __ ] money's gone yeah it is
crazy when you think of it in those
terms yeah yeah yeah which is sick i
mean if you've never been there there is
just some kind of like you know
i know energy is like a [ __ ]
hippy dippy [ __ ] but there is like some
ener like there's a an energy running
through that place you're like this is
[ __ ] crazy yeah the amount of people
that have just been through here there
is something cool about it isn't it
that's a safe neighborhood is it it's
like kind of maintained it's still like
a good place yeah
for sure for sure i mean it's very
touristy right around there and then if
you go a little past it it is kind of
that like
it's it's hilarious that in every
country it's like this where like the
downtown is like they're still trying to
sell you on the downtown where it's like
it's up and coming you know what i mean
yeah it is like that fully where they're
trying to gender like i got a hotel
there because and the hotel's super nice
but it's like they're like hey if um you
want us to escort you
out because it's like in an alley and
it's like this beautiful luxury hotel
but it's like a sketchy alley where like
somebody might be [ __ ] doing heroin
but there but it it's sick you know what
i mean right which to me
that is that does feel like double home
you know because like baltimore plus
greece i'm like yeah it's like i could
get mugged but it's still isn't that
weird that there's like people
homeless people and people doing heroin
and stuff like that but they're
surrounded by
this amazing history and culture yeah
yeah
like it's life is just happening yeah
yeah right i wonder what what junkies
were like i wonder
well i guess drunks i guess the town
drunk what the equivalent of junkies
were like 3 000 years ago yeah there had
to be some kind of herb or something
yeah like they're a chew cat yeah
i'm gonna look this up and the next time
i'm in athens i'm gonna i'm gonna get as
[ __ ] as [ __ ] up as that i'm gonna be
around in a tunic
dick out
on some kind of prehistoric drug look
and be like whoa
this is about the athens i'd like to see
you absolutely and honestly from new
york it's a it's a great it's an easy
flight it's like you know it's eight
hours nine hours direct but you know you
can get there pretty quick from jfk it's
nice where do you go for 10 days
dude i'm in uh like we grew up where
it's like if you didn't go like my
family never went for two months but
like that's how great like the greek
people in greek town where was like
businesses would just put a sign up in
june and we're like see in september and
they were just like like like
restaurants just be like we're just
closed for the summer good luck if you
wanna and they pulled it off so we would
go when i was growing up we'd go for
like five weeks uh and so i i go for
like two weeks but it still feels a
little it just feels a little short oh
okay because you're not it's not
supposed to like you're not there to be
a tourist you're there you would go you
would stay with me i mean it kind of
sucked to be honest when you're a little
ass kid because it's like i just want to
go to the beach we spent like
weeks in athens just like
watching television like literally what
we were do we would be watching the same
shows but with uh uh greek subtitles
underneath like it would be american
[ __ ] we'd be watching like you know
[ __ ] johnny bravo or whatever
[ __ ] cartoons we were watching and
then we would go
play hoops like or soccer and it's like
this is exactly what we were doing in
baltimore we're just doing it in greek
you know what i mean it's like but now
with no air conditioning but now it's
like hot as [ __ ] i'm in a little [ __ ]
apartment with my family i have to very
strategically beat off i'm 13. yeah
and there's tits in all media by the way
greece they got [ __ ] porn porn starts
at 10 p.m like they're just on
television like you could just watch
pornography on the like public channel
uh so there was there's that
uh and there's every magazine has tits
in it so i'm 13 but i'm in a [ __ ]
like literally we're in a one-bedroom
apartment with my entire family like how
do you get them all in the room together
to watch
my dad did walk in on me and my brother
watching a james bond themed pornography
and he just stayed and we were just
and me and my brothers just had to sit
there with our hard little ass dicks
with our dad and him him being like and
he was kind of walking us through it
like a co like it was a coach doing film
yeah you know what i mean yeah that's
what you want to do right there and it's
like first of all it's an absurd
james bond softcore pornography we're
not learning any moves here james bond
had a huge they showed his penis once
that was like they they didn't they
didn't show it the whole time and it was
like some kind of paper mache
18-inch penis that they made that they
faked but
yeah it was funny because our vacation
was like hey what if we downgraded our
lifestyle what do we want to do what if
we lived in a shittier country for a
long time yeah yeah yeah yeah i got i
loved rome it was nice but after like 10
days i was like all right i saw it like
i guess when you're just peeking around
a tourist [ __ ] oh yeah that's the thing
athens i would go for like
a solid like if i were if i were just
visiting like i would go for like four
or five days or like four days or
something see it all a lot of cool stuff
a lot of good you know restaurants all
that kind of stuff and then yeah go to
an island go [ __ ] yeah go get go to
you know don't go to mikko no but don't
go to big house but go [ __ ] anywhere
else knox was beautiful that chain of
islands this has turned into stavi's
little tourist tips for for the
listeners but that chain of islands is
just almost just as beautiful as like
mykonos or santorini but it's like go to
knoxville go to paros
there you go who was that guy who used
to go on tv when we were kids and try to
sell italian uh vacations oh i don't
know you know mario i think something
like the italian i know is chef tony in
his knives what was that was it pirillo
yeah mario pirillo yes
vacation
is that a tri-state thing i don't think
yeah probably yeah yeah it was probably
in the tri-state i remember yeah because
they used to run it on like fox oh like
box five i'd be watching my cartoons oh
[ __ ] we didn't get mystery marielle
is he dead
yeah because his son took over i've
dedicated 40 years of my life creating
this is what you got to do
from the alps to sicily pirillo takes
care of everything first-class hotels
meals sightseeing your own god can you
imagine uh one low price the disasters
that these vacations probably were
hundred percent call toll-free one eight
hundred mr italy
right now i wonder if they were
disasters or if it was one of those
things where it was all just like an
assembly line vacation like where
everything worked out okay because they
were in with the hotel yeah but yeah
there was other people there who just do
[ __ ] with totally and it's probably so
[ __ ] like you could get scammed so
much easier back then you just see a
picture and you're like i'm gonna this
is where i'm gonna go plus like
after they scam you what are you gonna
do tell your friend big deal yeah
exactly it's gonna take three years it's
one guy yeah yeah yeah exactly for 10
years yeah beautiful the age of scams
now it's oh perilla tour is still going
on yeah this is what you got to do you
got to make a video like stavros tours
tours
is the perfect name of course
to be a [ __ ] uh greek vacation pitch
man yeah yeah i just charged them
thousands of dollars to live with my
cousin leonidas
dude when i went there this [ __ ]
he was like i got your [ __ ] he was
like i got your bedroom all taken care
of everything's good to go and like
because i'm like i'm at the point where
it's like you know i don't have to stay
with family but you part of the reason
you go is to reconnect with them and i'm
like all right [ __ ] it i'll give him a
chance i'll he's he's talking up a big
game he's finally got his own apartment
he's a 36 year old man who literally
just got his own apartment he's been
living with his p and by the way his
parents now just lived downstairs that's
how he got his own apartment his parents
moved to the other apartment in the
building uh but he's like i got it all
set up for you
what he had set up for me was he had a
[ __ ] mattress that he had been
sleeping on since he was nine years old
that he just upgraded a mattress that
was purchased i guess in the first
george bush administration that was like
thin as [ __ ] mattress technology in
greece is really where i'm like all
right we're we're like greece
greece averages out the second world
because for some things it's like
exactly the same and some things it's
like
is this what are we in like a war-torn
yeah yemen right now like what the [ __ ]
is go how is this acceptable anyway this
[ __ ] my pillow guy come in and not
revolutionize listen yeah exactly they
haven't had him revolutionize their
pillows or their politics yet
um so he [ __ ] sets out this mattress
that he's had since he was literally a
[ __ ] child just puts it on the stone
floor there was no no there's a little
sheet over top of it and he was like
here and it was like next it was his
workout room so there's these like two
shitty rusty barbells like next to it
and he was like here you go
i literally i went on tour right after
that trip it was like right last year
when the pandemic kind of you felt like
okay traveling i was like all right i
want to go see my family then i'll go on
tour i had because i went from like
greece to straight to the west coast for
touring and i didn't get home until like
you know a month later i had chronic
back pain for four months because of the
hospitality my cousin showed me so you
stayed there i stayed there for for like
three days i stayed with him and then i
was like hey i'm gonna go visit some
friends you know what i'm just like and
then i started sleeping on the couch so
yeah i'm gonna do stavros tours and it's
gonna be my my cousin lil neither and
he's gonna [ __ ] put you on his
[ __ ] the mattress he slept on as a
baby and he's gonna take you to a
brothel afterwards
which he tried to do to my brother when
he was 11 years old
he tried to sneak my brother out and my
brother loved him and you know he's a
[ __ ] hilarious guy
rules honestly and hilariously he he
went to culinary school and then he just
became he just got a job this is how
greece is how show business works in
greece he just went to like an open
audition and he just got
a job working with the only big comedian
in greece so now he's just like a
comedic actor just because he was like
yeah i'll go on audition [ __ ]
i mean he went to acting school but it
was like yeah this is like the big this
is like if if you just went some guy
told you about an audition you just
ended up on saturday night live
that's the equivalent you know yeah he
wasn't he wasn't like yeah this wasn't
his dream it was yeah i mean he yeah he
wanted to do it but he's like everybody
exactly yeah yeah i want to see your
commercial it's gonna have like a
maury's wigs
yeah i jump into the pool i jump into i
just do back i'm just [ __ ] doing
backstrokes in the pool this could be
you
um does he speak english cousin yeah he
does okay yeah a little bit his um his
american his uh his uh uh attempted like
impersonating an american is hilarious
he's always like where is my dollars
i want hamburger where is my dollars
but yeah he literally tried to sneak my
11 year old brother out to get [ __ ] and
my brother was so he was so scared but
he didn't want to like disappoint him
and my mom caught him or else my brother
would have essentially been assaulted
through a prostitute by my cousin
my cousin would have essentially
molested my brother through some sex
trafficking ukrainian woman
you know 20 years ago or whatever whoa
i'm being a good cousin
hey come on he's got to get [ __ ]
sometimes
he's 11.
100 dude
is he famous there no but he's doing you
know he's doing well he's doing his boss
is hilariously famous and he's you know
he's he's crushing it for sure i mean
it's a big it's a it's a huge it's huge
but i like it because my family greece
does not know that i am successful like
so that's that's part of
yeah so no one has really asked for
money yet you know yeah
i think that's why you know it's like
part of me doesn't want to get like a
nice hotel when i visit because then
they'll know something's up
dude you gotta enjoy it
yeah i wish i had an angel on the devil
i just had two fat bobbies on my
shoulders tell me to get more appetizers
two broken shoulders